for me the most beautiful like Wildlife
are what I call uh God's mistakes yeah
because my friend came up with that term
where she's like you know God made these
disgusting animals just threw in the
bottom of the ocean he's like no one's
ever going to see this yeah you uh you
commented on Twitter about some creature
like a rainbow type creature the peacock
mantis shrimp yeah it's beautiful it's
horrific though so it has I think eight
leg legs six arms two punching claws or
spearing claws depending on the genus uh
two eyes two antenna two ear flaps I
don't know what they do um and its punch
can be as strong as a bullet and the
other type with the spears divers call
them thumb Splitters because if you
stick your finger near it it'll cut your
thumb down to the bone so I had one as a
pet all night I would hear banging on
the PVC pipe and I got to tell you they
have the best eyesight of any animal
look cuz they see in like seven
different ways and when you make eye
contact with this thing it's it's just
absolutely terrifying but you can eat
them as Sushi they call them C
centipedes but they're colorful and
beautiful that species is yeah what was
it like having one as a
pet and why did you do it well when you
have an species that's that unique and
that much of an outlier you know growing
up reading these books watching these
shows I found this stuff so much more
fascinating than like space and which is
you know dead um so to be able to have
this specimen in your house and just
observe Its Behavior um is just just
like an amazing thing why'd you get rid
of it I didn't have I guess the right
minerals in the mix because it had a
problem molting once yeah it couldn't
mol correctly wow you miss it think
about it still I do think about it to be
honest I still have a pair of its of a
punching um appendages from when it
moled